.
Böse Überraschung kurz
vor dem Notartermin in der Toskana.
Ah, Viertel vor.
Hallo Philippe,
du weisst das Neueste?
Nein?
Du weisst nichts?
- Nein, was?
Alberto hat dir gar nichts gesagt?
- Nein.
Auf keinen Fall unterschreiben.
- Wieso?
Sie wollen die Klausel rausnehmen,
dass das Landstück
sicher keine Altlasten hat.
Gehen wir hoch, wir sind sonst
zu spät. Sind sie schon da?- Ja.
Ich rede, bleib du ruhig.
- Ja. ist gut.
Wenn ich explodiere, dann fliegt
die ganze Sache in die Luft.
Leben in der Toskana.
Für ein eigenes Agriturismo
lösen Eva Dudle und Philippe
Sguaitamatti ihren Haushalt auf.
Buongiorno.
Beim Rundgang mit der Maklerin
entdeckt Philippe:
Eva will den Ofen
ebenerdig einbauen lassen.
Dass wir den Ofen
nicht auf Arbeitshöhe haben,
das will ich also definitiv nicht.
Ich habe jetzt mit Schrecken
festgestellt ...
Das ist nicht genau
unsere Abmachung.
Ach.
Für Mike Hostettler
wird ein Traum wahr:
Ich war schon früher immer
der Indianer- und Cowboyfreak.
Zusammen mit seiner Frau Marina und
Hündin Djuna zieht er in die USA.
In Florida wollen sie
ein Waffelrestaurant eröffnen.
Sie sind Franchisenehmer
einer Gastrokette.
Das Training im Waffelbacken
haben sie erfolgreich absolviert.
Unsere Strategie ist,
eine nach der anderen zu machen.
Familie Wieser
kehrt der Schweiz den Rücken zu
und wandert mit ihrer kleinen Herde
nach Frankreich aus.
Bauer Sandro glaubt, dort
erfolgreicher wirtschaften zu können.
Dort habe ich
eine andere Perspektive
und eine andere Cashflowmarge
auf der Milch.
Aber der Preis, den man
am Ende des Tages zahlt, ist,
dass man nicht mehr in
seinem angestammten Zuhause ist.
An der Atlantikküste
erwartet die Wiesers
ein riesiger Hof mit 400 Tieren.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# Uf u dervo ...
Tschüss,
melde dich und fahr vorsichtig.
Noch bleibt Aleksandra in Oberhof -
Sandro fährt schon voraus.
Der Tiertransporter mit Wiesers Herde
ist seit 4 Std. unterwegs.
Das Ziel: Saint-Même-le-Tenu.
Wir brauchen 12 Std. Geben wir Gas.
Wenn sie länger brauchen am Zoll,
dann können wir sie überholen.
Ansonsten kommen wir
fast gleichzeitig an.
Jeder kürzeste Transport
ist ein gewisses Risiko ...
... das man auf sich nimmt
resp. den Tieren auflastet.
Ich hoffe, dass es gut geht.
Das ist die erste grosse Reise
der Tiere.
* Erwartungsvolle Klänge *
Der Bauer möchte vor seinen Tieren
auf dem Hof in Frankreich ankommen.
* Piepsen *
Bei Auxerre, auf halber Wegstrecke,
kann er sie einholen.
So, da hätten wir sie.
Sie sehen noch zufrieden aus.
Sie schauen raus.
Gut, dass wir einen grossen
Lastwagen mit viel Platz haben.
* Rockige Version
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
# ... eifach uf u dervo.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Tampa in Florida.
Im Norden der Stadt,
in einer ruhigen Wohngegend,
haben Schweizer
die Berner Flagge gehisst.
Seit drei Monaten
ist der Cottontail Place
das neue Zuhause
von Marina und Mike.
Die ist von der Familie
und von Freunden.
Mit Sprüchen
und jeder hat unterschrieben.
Ja.
- Sie bedeutet uns sehr viel.
Wir als Berner
haben natürlich eine Berner Flagge.
* Marina lacht. *
Solothurn würde auch passen, Schatz,
weiss und rot.
Nein,
das wäre zu viel rot und weiss.
In den USA zu leben, davon
träumte Mike seit über 20 Jahren.
Und da Marina schon seit Kindertagen
das Fernweh plagt,
war sie sofort dabei.
Komm.
* Sie pfeift. *
Djuna, komm.
Einzige Bedingung:
Djuna, die Hündin, musste mit.
Djuna.
Ein eigenes Business:
ein Waffelshop in Tampa.
Für ein Leben in den USA
haben sie ihre Familien und Freunde
rund 8'000 km hinter sich gelassen.
Allein schon das Geräusch, Schatz.
Von diesem Ding.
* Klackern *
Das würdest du vermissen.
- Ja.
Das möchtest du nicht mehr missen.
Es ist einfacher,
um Mojito zu machen.
In den Filmen aus Amerika
ist es immer so cool,
wenn die Leute zum Kühlschrank gehen
und Eis rauslassen.
Das ist ein Bruchteil
des American Dream.
Doch ihr Traum kam ins Trudeln:
Kaum in den USA angekommen,
brach Corona aus.
Und Mike hat plötzlich viel Zeit.
Wenn es regnet oder windet,
sieht der Pool aus wie Sau.
Ich bin etwas pingelig.
Ich kann es nicht leiden,
wenn es Dreck und Mücken drin hat,
darum putze ich ihn
mindestens einmal am Tag.
Mit diesem Netz
bringt man alles raus.
Dann bin sogar ich zufrieden,
wenn es kein Stäubchen,
keinen Dreck mehr drin hat.
Da ich bin etwas pingelig.
Scheisse.
Wegen der Pandemie
kommt der Umbau ihres
Waffelrestaurants kaum vom Fleck.
Doch die Kosten laufen weiter:
Anschaffungen, Versicherungen,
Haus- und Lokalmiete
müssen trotzdem bezahlt werden.
Weiteres Problem: Die Einwanderungs-
behörde arbeitet nur reduziert,
Visumsverlängerungen
werden zur Zitterpartie.
Erst nach etlichen Mails und Anrufen
bekam Marina ihre Verlängerung
zugesichert.
Noch fehlt
die schriftliche Bestätigung.
Klar, man hat Tage ...
... Man hat so viel Planung
reingesteckt.
Plan A, Plan B.
Man hat auf und dieses und jenes
geachtet. Dann kommt Corona.
Gut.
Da kommen schon Zweifel auf:
Geht es weiter? Wie geht es weiter?
Wir sind mitten im Umbau.
Wir haben sehr viel Geld und Nerven
investiert.
Unsere Existenz hängt daran.
Ja, schlussendlich
hängt unsere Existenz daran.
Das sind ein paar Tausend Dollar.
Man sagt zwar, es sei nur Geld.
Aber es ist unser Geld
und unsere Existenz.- Genau.
Wir haben hier
ein neues Leben aufgebaut.
Uns war bewusst,
dass wir Stolpersteine haben.
Aber die letzten Wochen mit Corona
waren schlimmer
als in unseren schlimmsten Träumen.
Man kann nichts machen,
man ist machtlos.
Wir sind weit gekommen.
Es ist unmöglich,
dass Corona verhindert,
dass wir bis zum Schluss kommen.
Das ist unmöglich.
Genau.
Grosser Moment.
Die haben es sicher angepasst,
wenn sie es bestätigt haben.
* Sie seufzt. *
Siehe da, sie haben verlängert.
Sie hat immer gesagt:
"Mike, es kommt gut."
"Wir wissen nicht wann und wie,
aber es kommt gut."
Und sie hatte recht.
Du hasst es.
- Ich hasse es.
Er hasst es, wenn ich es sage und
wenn ich recht habe.- Wie die Pest.
Marina hat das Talent,
immer wieder das Beste
aus einer Situation zu machen.
Das scheint anzustecken.
Immerhin ist es warm.
- Ja.
Florida ...
... sunshine pur.
* Poppige Klänge *
* Die Musik klingt aus. *
Noch in der Schweiz, im Tösstal,
ist Eva Dudle.
Obwohl schon drei Jahre in Rente,
arbeitet sie noch immer.
Hallo.
- Grüss dich.
Ist irgendetwas?
Jetzt bist du auch rot,
macht nichts.
Partner Philippe
ist frisch pensioniert.
Willst du etwas zu trinken?
Ja, etwas Wasser gerne.
Du musst noch warten.
Mensch, sieht das aus hier!
Unordnung ahoi.
Zeig mir doch bitte
noch schnell das Logo von Joey.
Wir haben die Farbe noch nicht
ausgewählt, aber das Logo.
Rentenalter hin oder her:
Die beiden
sind mit hohem Tempo unterwegs.
Ich finde das besser.
Das finde ich ganz schön.
- Orange?
Das würde zur Wärme passen,
das Ockerfarbene.- Ja, genau.
Die ockerfarbene Toskana.
Dann sage ich es ihr ...
- Machen wir dieses da.
Vielleicht ist es das Alter.
Entschlüsse sind schnell gefasst Ð
kleine Differenzen bald vergessen.
Ihr Zwist wegen des Ofens, darüber
kann Philippe heute nur noch lachen.
Also der Backofen ist unten.
Etwas anders.
Wir haben alle noch etwas Wasser
in den Wein gegossen.
Gell, du.
Ja, ja. Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Den Staubsauger
musst du nicht einpacken.
Ich weiss, der kommt in dein Auto.
Ins Auto?
Den nimmst du mit,
damit du saugen kannst.
Damit wir irgendwann Sachen
auf einen einigermassen sauberen
Boden stellen können.
Du hast schon einen Job bekommen.
Philippe reist voraus.
Noch wenige Tage,
und der ehemalige Sicherheits-
beauftragte der Flughafenpolizei
wird seine neue Aufgabe als Guts-
verwalter ihres Agriturismo antreten.
Die Fahrt durch Frankreich
verlief optimal.
Jetzt kommt links La Croix,
dann muss ich rechts abbiegen. Hier.
* Der Blinker klickt. *
So, jetzt sind wir auf der Strasse.
* Das Handy klingelt. *
Mutti ruft an.
Schatzi?
- Hoi.
Hallo, Gian.
- Wie weit bist du?
Ich bin gleich dort.
Wie weit bist du?
- Ich bin gleich dort.
Bist du 200 gefahren?
Mein Gott.
Okay, ich lass dich.
- Ja.
Viel Spass beim Ausladen,
sag Grüsse.- Sag ich.
Bis dann, tschüss.
- Tschau, tschau.
Im Stall
erwartet ihn Patrice Rondeau.
Salut.
Et les affaires? Dans la voiture?
Rondeau ist einer der Vorbesitzer
des Hofs Les Aubiers.
Er wird Sandro auch nach dem Verkauf
unterstützen.
Gegen 22 Uhr dann kommt auch Sandros
kleine Herde aus dem Aargau an.
* Entferntes Muhen. *
Jetzt bin ich aufgeregt.
Ich frage mich, wie sie aussteigen.
Mach vorwärts.
* Muhen *
* Sandro pfeift. *
Elle est curieuse.
Komm, Elodie.
Komm, Mädchen.
Steig aus.
Allez, komm.
* Kuhglocken bimmeln. *
* Muhen *
Zufrieden, ja. Wenn dann die Kleinen
noch draussen sind.
* Hoffnungsvolle Akkordeonklänge *
Allez, allez, hop, hop, hop.
* Pfeifen *
* Unverständliches Gespräch
auf Französisch. *
Endlich wieder rumspringen - zum
ersten Mal in französischem Stroh.
Geschafft.
Ich bin geschafft,
die Viecher sind geschafft
und wir haben es geschafft.
Jetzt bin ich froh.
Ich hatte etwas Schiss,
dass das nicht so funktioniert,
wie ich will.
Es ist gut.
Passt.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenklänge *
Die südliche Toskana,
die Maremma, ist die neue Heimat
von Eva und Philippe.
Als Gutsverwalter trifft Philippe
mit Gärtner Massimo Massai
die ersten Vorkehrungen.
Damit sie als Agriturismo gelten,
müssen die Zürcher Vorlagen erfüllen.
Eine davon: Landwirtschaft betreiben.
Philippe lässt 800 Olivenbäume
anpflanzen.
Ein kleines Stück Erde
seines Olivenhains
ist anders beschaffen als der Rest.
... vicino sono più forti.
Ein Stück Land,
auf dem nichts wächst -
noch nimmt es Philippe gelassen.
Tampa in Florida.
Fünf Autominuten
von zu Hause entfernt
haben Mike und Marina das Geschäfts-
lokal für ihren Waffelshop gemietet.
Dieses befindet sich - so
richtig amerikanisch - in einer Mall:
dem Grand Plaza Shopping Center.
Typisch auch:
Hier gibt es viele Parkplätze.
* Entspannte Popklänge *
Das ist
eine der ältesten strip-malls
am North Dale Mabry Highway
von Tampa.
Aber sie ist sehr gut erhalten.
Der landlord
steckt sehr viel Geld hinein,
er saniert und renoviert
immer wieder.
Wir sind neben einem Barbershop
und einer Boutique.
Und zwar genau hier.
Ursprünglich glaubten die beiden,
dass sie ihr Restaurant zwei Monate
nach Ankunft in den USA eröffnen.
Aber wegen Corona
dauerte es nur schon drei Monate,
bis sie die Bewilligungen
für den Umbau erhielten.
Dann waren Baumaterialien
kaum zu bekommen
und Handwerker fielen Corona-bedingt
immer wieder aus.
Sie wären hier, es brennt Licht,
die Maschinen sind bereit ...
... aber es ist 12.15 Uhr,
die sind beim Essen.
Die Frage ist, wann sie wieder
kommen, um 13 oder 14 Uhr?
Ich glaube,
sie kommen um 12.30 oder 12.45
und machen um 15.30 Feierabend.
Ja, meistens
sind sie um 15 Uhr Geschichte.
So ist es nun mal.
Von Tag zu Tag ein kleiner
Fortschritt, step by step.
Welcher Boden geht bis dort hinten?
- Bis hier.
Der gleiche?
Dann legt er hier Fliessen.
Dann kommt das Elektrische
und die Wände davor.
Ein grosser Teil ihres Ersparten
steckt nun in diesen Wänden.
Wegen der Verzögerung aber verlieren
sie seit Wochen täglich Geld -
viel Geld.
Genau.
Jetzt müssen wir ihn fragen.
Okay, perfect.
Jetzt wird es laut,
ich gehe auf die Seite.
* Marina lacht. *
Um mittelfristig das mehrjährige
Investorenvisum zu erhalten,
investieren Marina und Mike
viel Geld.
Die Gesamtsumme,
die wir hier bezahlen,
ist vermutlich schon hoch.
Aber wir mussten uns entscheiden.
Der Umbau im Laden rund 70'000 ¤.
Mhm.
Dazu kommt das ganze Equipment,
die Möblierung und Deko.
Man muss Gewisses investieren,
damit man ein Visum bekommt ...
Wir haben schon vorher
extrem viel investiert.
Einen gewissen Betrag
muss man investieren.
Alles in allem,
über den Daumen gepeilt,
kostet uns rund 200'000 Fr.
Da werden wir uns bewegen.
Bis wir endlich starten können.
* Die Maschine surrt. *
Sehr schön!
Mein Herz schlägt schon schneller.
Je näher es kommt.
Endlich
den innerlichen Drang und Wunsch,
hier in Amerika, Florida,
verwirklichen zu dürfen,
macht mich schon extrem stolz.
Jetzt wird es gut.
* Akkordeonversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
* Entferntes Bimmeln *
Über Nacht ist der Schweizer Sandro
Grossbauer in Frankreich geworden.
Heute melkt er seine riesige Kuhherde
zum ersten Mal - 200 Tiere.
Kommt.
Allez!
- Kommt. Los, los.
Das gilt für alle.
Allez gilt für alle.
Gut 6'500 l Milch gibt
seine Holstein-Herde täglich.
Patrice Rondeau und eine Melkerin
arbeiten mit.
Es ist sehr effizient und einfach.
Es geht relativ zügig.
Kostenübersichtlich, das passt.
Man kann im schlimmsten Fall
auch allein melken.
* Rhythmisches Pumpen
der Melkmaschinen. *
* Entspannte Akkordeon-
und Schlagzeugklänge *
Doch noch wichtiger
ist ihm heute das Jungvieh.
Die sieben Kälber
haben die erste Nacht in Frankreich
bestens überstanden,
sie haben Hunger - ein gutes Zeichen.
Voilà.
Was ist das?
Komisches Zeugs.
Während für den Vater
das neue Leben begonnen hat,
heisst es für seinen
achtjährigen Sohn Abschied nehmen.
Ich muss dort vorne nachschauen.
Auch Mama ist dabei, wenn ihr
Jüngster den letzten Schultag hat.
(Frau) So Gian,
deine allerletzten Minuten bei uns.
Kommt etwas näher.
Wir haben etwas Kleines
für dich vorbereitet.
Lenn, darf ich dich bitten?
Das ist für dich,
ein Andenken an uns alle.
Danke.
Alle Kinder haben dir
eine Seite gemalt und geschrieben.
Auch Frau Cuccaro
und ich haben noch etwas gemalt.
Nino hat auch noch etwas.
Lieber Gian,
ich habe hier
ein T-Shirt von uns allen
mit unseren Handabdrücken darauf.
Dann kannst du immer die Grösse
unserer Handabdrücke vergleichen.
Wir haben vorne extra
"à bientôt" geschrieben.
Das heisst bis bald.
- Mhm.
Wir hoffen sehr,
dich wieder zu sehen.
Und euch wünsche ich
wunderschöne Ferien.
(Alle) Wir Ihnen auch.
Danke, bis bald. Tschüss.
- (Alle) Tschüss!
War Gian traurig in der Schule?
- Ja.
Schon?
Aber er musste nicht weinen?
- (Gian) Hoi!
Hoi, Grosser.
Soll ich dir etwas abnehmen?
Weil Papa schon weg ist,
ist Gians Götti da.
Hoi.
* Stimmengewirr der Kinder *
* Mehrfaches Hupen *
Notartermin in der Toskana.
Als Geschäftsführer
will Philippe heute
die Unterschrift
unter den Kaufvertrag setzen.
Eine Formalie, denn der Vorvertrag
ist schon lange unterzeichnet.
Seine Maklerin aber
hat eine böse Überraschung.
Hallo Philippe.
Du weisst das Neueste?
- Nein?
Du weisst nichts?
- Nein. Was?
Alberto hat dir gar nichts gesagt?
- Nein.
Auf keinen Fall unterschreiben.
- Wieso?
Sie wollen die Klausel
aus dem Vertrag rausnehmen,
in der sie uns versichern,
dass das Landstück
sicher keine Altlasten hat.
Im Sinne von vergrabenem Material
und was weiss ich nicht alles.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Wir sagen, dass wir einen Monat
Verlängerung wollen.
In diesem Monat kontrollieren
wir und machen Bodenproben.
Wenn alles in Ordnung ist,
unterschreiben wir,
sonst können sie uns
das Geld zurückgeben.
* Er seufzt. *
Gehen wir hoch, wir sind sonst
zu spät. Sind sie schon da?- Ja.
Ich rede, bleib du ruhig.
- Ja. ist gut.
Wenn ich explodiere, dann fliegt
die ganze Sache in die Luft.
Dabei bekäme er heute seine Schlüssel
fürs Gut.
Im zürcherischen Greifensee
arbeitet die künftige
Agriturismo-Besitzerin Eva
noch immer als Kindergartenlehrerin.
* Gemächliche Klänge *
* Stimmengewirr *
So, es kann nicht jeder
etwas machen,
sonst gibt es kein Schloss
miteinander.
Kinder haben Evas
ganzes Leben bestimmt:
im Beruf und auch privat.
Die 67-Jährige
ist Mutter von sieben Kindern.
Ja, ich schaue.
Es ist genug,
nicht noch mehr nehmen.
Es ist Eva, die den grössten Teil
des Geldes für das Gut einbringt.
Dafür hat sie ein Haus verkauft.
Die Rentnerin ist froh,
weiterhin Geld verdienen zu können.
Wir sagten von Anfang an,
dass ich noch in der Schweiz bleibe
und weiter arbeite.
Das wollte ich auch.
Er soll die Aufbauarbeiten machen
und das Ganze mit den Behörden.
Ich kann nicht so gut Italienisch,
das könnte ich nicht machen.
Zum Abschluss
machen die Ritter ein Tor
und die Prinzessinnen
dürfen darunter durchgehen
und sich anziehen.
In der Toskana
gibt es gute Neuigkeiten.
Der Notar hat die Forderung des
Verkäufers kategorisch abgewiesen.
Die Klausel bleibt.
Warte kurz.
Ich muss das ablegen,
die Schlüssel sind so schwer.
An einem anderen Ort
hättest du zwei oder drei Schlüssel.
Das ist ein ganzes Schlüsselpaket.
Mit allen Schlüsseln drin.
Das ist nur ein kleiner Teil.
Die Erleichterung ist gross.
Ja?
- Ja, hallo.
Bist du jetzt Besitzer oder
Geschäftsführer eines Agriturismo?
Ich wollte soeben sagen,
Besitzer stimmt nicht.
Aber Geschäftsführer
eines Agriturismo
mit etwa 200 Schlüsseln.
* Eva lacht. *
Du kannst schon lachen.
Aller Anfang ist schwer.
Aber wenn wir in zwei Jahren
darüber nicht lachen,
dann haben wir etwas falsch gemacht.
Jetzt musst du
mal eine Pause machen.
Das stimmt.
Du hast recht.
- Eben.
Wie immer hast du recht.
Tschüss, tschau, tschau.
- Tschüss, tschau.
Florida, The Sunshine State.
Der Südstaat macht seinem Namen
alle Ehre, jeden Tag:
Auch die Stimmung der Auswanderer
ist prächtig.
Ihr American Dream
nimmt nämlich wieder Fahrt auf.
Der Umbau des Waffelshops
ist kurz vor der Vollendung.
Zeit, die seit Langem gekauften
und bezahlten Möbel und Arbeitsgeräte
endlich auszupacken.
Schauen wir mal.
- Das brauchst du gerade nicht?
Wie viele Stühle
hast du auf der Liste?
Zehn hellgraue und von diesen acht.
Voilà,
das ist wirklich das Heiligtum,
das Herzstück unseres Ladens,
davon haben wir drei Stück.
Drei Doppelwaffeleisen.
Die werden in Deutschland
hergestellt.
Es sind zwei Hersteller.
Sie werden umgerüstet,
damit es in Amerika passt.
Das hat funktioniert.
- Das hat funktioniert.
Das ist tipptopp.
Das ist einwandfrei bis jetzt.
Doch ohne Foodmanager-Zertifikat
keine Eröffnung.
Um ein Restaurant zu führen, muss man
in Florida eine Prüfung ablegen.
Themen sind: Hygiene, Sicherheit,
Viren und Bakterien im Gastgewerbe.
Hier ist alles sehr detailliert.
Jetzt büffeln wir und in den
nächsten Tagen machen wir den Test,
den kann man online machen.
Ein Prüfungsexperte beobachtet einen
mit Kamera und Spiegeln,
um zu sehen, dass man
kein Material auf dem Tisch hat.
Das müssen wir bestehen,
wir haben etwas Druck.
Als Jungunternehmer müssen die beiden
auch die Finanzen im Griff haben.
Marina ist gelernte Kauffrau.
Ihr Wissen kann sie nun
im eigenen Business anwenden.
Noch aber unterstützt sie
Buchhalter Ken.
Ich muss viel lernen.
Doppelte Buchhaltung
ist schon lange her.
Aber ich mache es gerne
und es interessiert mich.
Ich möchte den Überblick haben.
Ich will wissen,
wo was hingeht und warum.
Wo kann man Kosten einsparen,
damit man genügend Umsatz macht?
Du bist froh.
Ich bin froh, dass ich mich
nicht damit rumschlagen muss.
Ich verstehe nur Bahnhof.
Ich tue nur so,
als ob ich es verstehen würde.
Nein, es ist gut so, wie es ist.
Wir haben das klar aufgeteilt.
Dann erzählst du mal etwas
und ich tue so,
als ob es mich interessieren würde.
Das merke ich schon.
Kein Neuanfang ohne Abschied.
Heute wandern auch
Aleksandra und Gian aus.
Die erwachsenen Kinder Sascha
und Joana bleiben in der Schweiz.
(Tränenerstickt)
... Tschüss zu sagen.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Das war ein Stress. Ist's gut?
Tschüss.
- Tschüss, Grosser.
(Joana) Tschüss.
* Schluchzen *
* Schwere Klavierklänge *
Alles gut, sie kommen ja.
Haben wir alles? Maske?
Gell.
Tschüss. Love you.
Tschüss.
Ich glaube, eher ich bin traurig.
Aber das ist der ganze Stress.
Komm, Gian.
Schau, tschüss!
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Einen Tag nach der Ankunft
in Frankreich
ist die Übergabe des Wohnhauses.
Bonjour, Patrice.
Très bien, et toi ?
Bonjour, Gian.
Gian! Er sagt "hallo" zu dir.
Schauen wir schnell.
Bonjour, Monsieur.
- Bonjour.
Gerade mal zehn Monate ist es her,
dass sie den Hof Les Aubiers
entdeckt hatten.
Im Eiltempo zogen die Wiesers
die Kaufverhandlungen durch.
Gleichzeitig verkauften sie
ihr Heim in Oberhof.
Aleksandra sieht das Wohnhaus
erst zum zweiten Mal.
Ein schöner Tisch.
Oui.
170 m2 hat das Haus.
Da ist ja ein Schrank.
Sohn Gian bekommt sogar
sein eigenes Badezimmer.
Wird das dein Zimmer?
Du musst sagen: "C'est bon."
Dort oben können wir LED-Bänder
hinmachen.
Aha. LED.
- LED-Bänder.
Oui, voilà.
Hier muss man gar nichts machen.
Sogar noch eine schöne Farbe ...
aber er will grau.
Total schnuckelig.
Es ist hell, das gefällt mir.
Oh mein Gott.
- Was ist nicht gut?
Das wird renoviert.
Das wird renoviert, ja.
Was wird renoviert?
Das Badezimmer?
- Le petit chef.
Oh mein Gott, Kind,
du bist verwöhnt.
Du kannst öffnen.
Eine riesige Garage
gehört auch dazu -
mit Platz für vier Autos.
Tipptopp, oben muss man noch
etwas machen, aber ...
Okay.
- Gut.
Es ist um einiges besser
als bei der Übernahme des Oberhofs,
damals übernahmen wir
eine Müllhalde.
Das Haus war nicht bewohnbar,
das hier schon.
Es ist okay.
Man kann schon noch
ein paar Sachen machen.
V.a. ich muss immer etwas umbauen.
Nein, es ist wirklich gut.
Man herfahren, melken,
es ist alles gemacht.
Bonjour.
Vier Tage noch,
und die Schweizer feiern mit monate-
langer Verspätung das Soft Opening.
Eine Art Generalprobe
vor der richtigen Eröffnung.
Der Raum ist wie vorgeschrieben
gestrichen.
Das sieht aus wie damals
mein Kinderschrank.
Aber es ist gut?
Auch die typischen Klinkerwände
sind angebracht.
Good.
Als Franchisenehmer müssen
die beiden künftigen Gastronomen
die Einrichtungsvorgaben
des Hauptgeschäfts einhalten.
Und monatlich eine Gebühr bezahlen.
Du kannst dich hinsetzen.
Im Gegenzug können sie das Know-how
eines erfolgreichen und erprobten
Geschäftsmodells nutzen.
Es ist gar nicht
so unbequem ohne ...
... Kissen.
Yes.
Cool.
Doch noch fehlen
viele kleine Details.
Was macht er damit?
Er versetzt sie.
Jetzt montieren sie die Lampen.
Das WonderWaffel-Sign
kommt noch auf die rechte Seite,
zusammen mit den Pflanzen.
So sieht unser Laden
hoffentlich diesen Sonntagabend aus,
Nicht ganz genau gleich.
Das ist vom Architekten,
vom deutschen Franchisegeber,
er hat uns das erstellt.
Aber es sieht in etwa so aus,
wenn es fertig ist.
Also in vier Tagen.
Zum ersten Mal das Tor öffnen
im Bewusstsein,
dass es mir bzw. uns gehört.
Das ist ein Meilenstein.
Die Zürcher haben
eine einfache Gesellschaft gegründet:
eine società agricola semplice.
Eva ist Kapitalgeberin,
Philippe
Administrator der Gesellschaft.
Bald schon kommen die Möbel
aus der Schweiz.
Viele davon werden vorerst
in dieser Garage eingestellt.
* Geschäftige Klänge *
Dort hinten ist es drin.
Jetzt geht es.
* Seufzer *
Nur der Kühlschrank
hat bereits den richtigen Platz.
Mal schauen, ob ich den grossen
Zusammenschiss von Eva bekomme.
Ich habe effektiv vergessen
abzumessen.
Wenn ich Pech habe,
ist er breiter, als er sein sollte.
Ich hoffe nicht.
Sonst sehe ich alt aus.
Nein, nein, nein, es ist super.
Ob Können oder Glück - es passt.
Prompt kommt der andere
mit dem Traktor.
Mit dem Bauern von nebenan
hat Philippe
bereits Freundschaft geschlossen.
Und der ist völlig unkompliziert.
* Handyklingeln *
Grüezi.
Und, hast du ausgeladen?
- Was heisst ausgeladen?
Es ist alles ...
- Sind sie da?
Sie sind vor 2 Min. angekommen.
Im Ernst?
- Ja.
Oh, oh.
- So, wir verteilen es.
Alles klar.
- Alles klar.
Gut, tschüss.
- Also, tschüss.
Philippe und Eva
kannten sich knapp zwei Jahre,
als sie beschlossen, sich auf
das Abenteuer Toskana einzulassen.
Eigentlich
wäre nun alles auf bestem Wege.
Doch während ihr Agriturismo
langsam Form annimmt,
wachsen Evas Zweifel.
Sie stellt ihre Beziehung
mit Philippe zunehmend infrage.
Zu viel trennt sie,
zu wenig eint sie.
Nach langem Grübeln der Entschluss:
Eva trennt sich von Philippe.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Auf und Davon":
Sie hat mir unmissverständlich
klargemacht,
dass sie keine Beziehung
mehr mit mir möchte.
Eva kommt das erste Mal
seit der Trennung nach Italien.
Ich habe mich hier einquartiert.
Wenn du willst, kannst du auch
hierher kommen, mir ist es egal.
Ich bin einfach sehr dominant.
Das muss man klar sehen.
Aus Liebe soll Freundschaft werden,
ihr Projekt ziehen sie weiter.
Gemeinsam entnehmen sie
eine Bodenprobe des Olivenhains.
Zahltag in Frankreich:
Die Wiesers greifen allein
fürs Inventar tief in die Tasche.
Sohn Gian hat seinen ersten Schultag.
Bist auch so eine Gundula.
Grosseinkauf in Tampa.
Morgen ist das Soft Opening.
Ich bin sehr aufgeregt und nervös.
Es läuft einiges schief.
# U si stiige in Flüüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chömme nümme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neuis Dihei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Michaela Hoss - 2022